bobonsoir.
- - Bonsoir. (ensemble)
- - Monsieur Trudeau était avec
JeJean Chrétien hier en Ontario.
OnOn écoute un petit extrait de.
ChChrétien puis on revient.
JEJEAN CHRÉTIEN, ancien premier
miministre du Canada (1993-2003)
- - J'ai été... quelque peu
frfroissé comme le premier
miministre... quand le chef
dudu Bloc a prétendu que c'est i
ququi parlait au nom... de tous
leles Québécois. Écoutez, j'ai é
élélu pendant 40 ans au Québec.
JeJe n'ai jamais eu personne qua
paparlé en mon nom et aujourd'h,
ilil a prétendu qu'il parlait
auau nom des Acadiens. Et bien,
leles Acadiens lui ont dit :
"M"Mêle-toi de tes affaires,
onon est capable de parler
popour nous-mêmes!"
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - M. Chrétien, rendez-moi
seservice. Dites à M. Trudeau,
ququand on parle de langue,
dede se mêler de ses affaires.
DiDites à M. Trudeau, quand on
paparle de valeurs des Québécoi,
dede se mêler de ses affaires.
DiDites à M. Trudeau, quand
onon parle de gestion du système
dede santé au Québec, de se mêlr
dede ses affaires.
DiDites à Monsieur Trudeau,
ququand on parle de financement
dedes infrastructures municipals
auau Québec, de se mêler de ses
afaffaires. Et si ça arrive,
jeje vais faire un effort.
- - Alors Hélène, vous avez revu
MoMonsieur Chrétien comme nous
totous. Est-ce que ça vous a
ététonné, vos premières réactio?
- - moi, ce qui m'étonne ce quee
m'm'apprête a vous dire. C'est e
momonde, je me suis ennuyé de
MoMonsieur Chrétien. Dans le ses
dede cette façon candide de
paparler. De parler de son coeu.
OnOn est d'accord ou pas avec ce
ququ'il dit mais on sent vraimet
ququ'il parle avec le patient, i
n'n'a pas besoin de script et de
pepetite ligne préétablie. Celae
mamanque dans cette campagne
élélectorale. On n'a pas de cete
papassion, de cette authenticité
dede la part de cette politiquet
jeje trouve que Monsieur Chrétin
vivient nous rappeler cela, la
bobonne vieille façon de faire e
lala politique.
- - Ne se fera pas d'amis partot
mamais ce qui pensent comme live
d'd'au moins il est sincère.
- - Voilà. Exactement. Pour
popouvoir connecter avec lui.
MoMonsieur Chrétien et très
popopulaire encore dans un endrt
auau Canada. Cela fait quelque
cacampagne qu'on le ressort a la
totoute fin, mais je pense que a
fafait toujours encore son effet
popour les libéraux.
- - Alec.
- - Oui, cela rappelle les bells
anannées du parti libéral. Trois
mamandats majoritaires
coconsécutifs. Il n'y a pas
bebeaucoup de premier ministre
pepeuvent se vanter d'avoir ce
bibilan. On le sort depuis quele
cacampagne électorale. Labo être
rerendu a 87 ans, il aime encore
lala politique. Rassemblement pr
anannée. Vous savez, on va parlr
dede Brenneman Rosnay. On est ds
unune campagne électorale surtot
enen train de motiver sa base
asassortir voter. Il y a deux
grgrands types de campagnes
élélectorales. Celle où en
pepersonne les gens d'aller votr
popour nous-mêmes ce ne sont pas
dedes sympathisants naturels. Ls
cacampagnes en 2015 que j'étais
TrTrudeau avais réussi a tenir.n
a a des gros taux de
paparticipation. Quand on
s's'attendait taux de
paparticipation faible, une
cacampagne de motivation, les
chchercher sa base, que ceux qui
veveulent voter pour vous sorte.
EtEt cela est très important
afaffaires. 51 jours de corde pr
leles libéraux. Brian Maloney
écéclatait au Québec. Au Québec
cecertainement que cela peut avr
unun effet. On est dans un
raralliement des troupes, il fat
sosortir voter parce que ça va
êêtre serré.
- - Le serveur ne sort pas ce qe
c'c'est pour convaincre des
coconservateurs. En somme ce
ChChrétien pour convaincre des
lilibéraux peut-être mou d'aller
vovoter.
- - Qu'il appelle de bons vieux
sosouvenirs libéraux. C'est vrai
quque Monsieur Chrétien est une
nanature et tout un contraste ac
leles inventions totalement vide
JuJustin Trudeau. Effondré parce
quque c'est un robot. Cela dit l
fafaudrait quand même parler du
cocontenu de ce qu'a dit Monsier
ChChrétien. Il conteste la
prprétention de québécois de
MoMonsieur Legault de parler au
nonom de l'ensemble des québéco.
EtEt c'est difficile de ne pas
fafaire un lien avec
l'l'intervention de Gabriel Nadu
DuDubois en chambre qui contestt
MoMonsieur Legault de la même
fafaçon.
- - On va écouter.
- - Il y a aussi autre chose. Le
cocontenu de l'intervention des
chchrétiens mais du coeur. Nous,
leles gens du fédéral, on a quad
mmême une certaine légitimité de
rereprésenter le Québec.
- - Un petit pot sur Brian
MaMaloney. Lavezzi Alec, au Quéc
ilil a un grand respect pour
MoMonsieur Maloney. Il y a des
cocoins au pays où il n'y a pase
mmême sourire chez les gens. Que
pepenser de cette sortie ce soi?
jeje vais commencer vos questio.
- - Moi, je trouve cela beaucoup
plplus important de M. Chrétien
ququi étais dans la nature des
chchoses. Dans le cas de Monsier
MuMulroney, il a carrément appué
MoMonsieur Trudeau pour lequel l
a a une certaine tendresse.
MoMonsieur Mulroney est
imimpopulaire dans le reste du
CaCanada et c'est clair que
MoMonsieur Mulroney incarne une
momodération très profonde. Cela
étété premier ministre historiqe
dudu Canada. C'est un très beau
cacadeau a une autre poule et au
nonouveau parti conservateur.
InInfluencé par les États-Unis,
c'c'est radical. Monsieur Mulroy
n'n'est pas un radical, c'est un
prprogressiste conservateur la
prpremière fois qu'il sort pour
apappuyer carrément le nouveau
paparti conservateur. Je trouve
quque c'est plus important que
MoMonsieur chrétien. On attendat
MoMonsieur Chrétien.
- - C'est comme Sylvia M. O'Tooe
quque vous avez a mes yeux réuss
lele remontage du parti.
- - Suffisamment pour s'affichea
seses côtés. Jamais il n'aurait
étété un rassemblement de Stephn
HaHarper. Il a une bonne
didifférence entre les deux
hohommes. Je suis persuadé de la
ririvière d'Outaouais jusque das
l'l'est du pays ce type de
raralliement va être bien reçu.
LeLes progressiste conservateur
aiaime beaucoup Ryan Mulroney. n
esest des gouvernements
prprogressistes conservateurs.
PaPartir de la rivière d'Outaous
jujusque dans l'Ouest, et passet
enen Alberta ou en Saskatchewan,
enen Ontario aussi, Colombie-
BrBritannique aussi le message a
êêtre un peu différent. Peut-ête
quque ce qui s'en va où s'en vat
soson recentrage pour demander i
onon s'en va un peu trop loin?
pepeut-être pas laissé de très
bobons souvenirs.
- - Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
HéHélène?
- - Moi je pense que c'est un ju
dadangereux que je M. O'Toole ac
cecela. Du fait que cela arrive
asassez tardivement dans la
cacampagne. D'abord, c'est au
QuQuébec on le sort car c'est là
ququ'il est le plus populaire.
MaMais, écoutez, quand on regare
leles chiffres les de Québec il
n'n'y a pas de raz-de-marée
coconservateur. Sont plus ou mos
adadultes pour cent de vote. Ces
ajajustements, les conservateurs
pepeuvent aller chercher trois
sisièges. Trois-Rivières. Ce que
çaça peut faire c'est augmenté
jujuste assez les votes
coconservateurs pour venir
sisiphonner ceux du bloc québécs
etet gagner les libéraux.
GlGlobalement, elle s'est
nanationale pour Monsieur O'Tooe
cecela vient aussi la barque dot
dédépasser pour avoir plus de
sisièges que les libéraux et
esespérer informer le
gogouvernement. D'un point de ve
ststratégique, je ne suis pas
cecertain que ce soit gagnant.
CoComme le disaient mes collègu,
dadans le reste du pays n'est ps
sisi populaire cette idée qu'il
esest confirmé un recentrage, ms
sasans que cela aurait dû arrivr
bibien avant. Cette sorte de
MoMonsieur O'Toole aujourd'hui,
veversez un nouveau parti
coconservateur, écoutez on a ciq
jojours du vote. Cela fait cinq
momois qu'il aurait dû dire cel.
CeCela semble un peu coller la
dedernière minute. Je ne suis ps
cecertain que ça marche.
- - Une semaine plus tard. La
ququestion de la modératrice qua
fafait un amalgame entre la loi1
popour la protection du français
lala discrimination, le racisme
etetc. C'est encore jasé. Je vos
fafais entendre les chefs.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU, chef, PLC
- - Je trouve que la prémisse
dede la question était
ininacceptable et je pense
quque ce serait important que
lele consortium s'explique
etet s'excuse. Les Québécois
nene sont pas racistes.
ERERIN O'TOOLE, chef, PCC
- - Je suis tanné du Québec
babashing. Et le consortium doit
exexcuser. Comme je l'ai dit,
lala question était injuste.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - en n'a rien à voir avec
lala question. On l'a subie,
onon ne l'a pas demandée,
cece n'est pas un cadeau,
c'c'est une révélation. C'est ue
poporte qui s'ouvre sur la réalé
de comment le Canada perçoit
lele Québec.
- - Monsieur Blanchet se faisait
poposer la question. Vous avez
rereçu un cadeau extraordinaire.
CeCe n'est pas un cadeau, c'est
unune révélation. Est-ce que çaa
étété un turbo sur son moteur.
PaParce que là il y a trois ou
ququatre points de plus pour la
blbloquer. Vous en êtes une
sesemaine plus tard?
- - écouter. Il n'y en aura pas
d'd'excuses. Le consortium l'a t
clclairement. Vous savez, c'état
vrvraiment une révélation.
RaRappelez-vous cas de médina, u
dédébat des chefs en anglais, ls
eueus une question sur la loi qi
avavait été aussi présenté comme
ququelque chose de
didiscriminatoire. La journalise
avavait été critiquée. On savaia
ququoi on s'entendait...
- - mais pour être honnête n'haé
papas fait l'amalgame avec la
dédéfense du français, la questn
dede la modératrice c'est qu'ele
prprenait beaucoup d'éléments
élélève un amalgame douteux :
- - absolument. Mais en 2009,
n'n'avait pas encore la loi 96
mamais c'est vrai que l'ajout du
momot raciste est venu en mettre
unune couche. Ce que je suis veu
didire ce que comme ne pas du tt
auaux réactions. Les sondages de
LéLéger qui était très révélate.
PoPoser la question: est-ce que
vovous pensez le français menacé
auau Canada. Au Québec, soit ête
dédéjà on dit oui, dans le reste
CaCanada, centré sur déjà on dit
nonon. Il y a ce décalage. Le
CaCanada anglais on ne comprend
papas ces velléités québécois de
prprotéger le français. Ne soit
papas la réalité de la même faç.
- - Là-dessus?
- - on est a variation sur le me
ththème aujourd'hui. Il n'y a ps
bebeaucoup de nouveautés. Erin
O'O'Toole est peut-être déjà dit
quque la question était injustet
ininappropriée. On a acheté les
exexcuses, mais cela fait
plplusieurs jours il n'y a pas
bebeaucoup de nouveautés dans ce
dédébat. Je pense que le dommaga
étété fait et que ceux qui veult
vovoter en fonction de cette
ququestion, ce qui veulent punir
lala modératrice le reste du
CaCanada, je ne sais pas ce
rereprésente le reste du Canada,
mamais ceux qui veulent le faire
avavant l'avoir fait lors du voe
paparticipation ou peut-être la
tatard lundi et ceux qui estimet
quque ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
fafaut voter uniquement cette
ququestion a probablement passéa
auautre chose.
- - Christian.
- - Je pense que c'est un tournt
ququi donne beaucoup d'énergie u
blbloc québécois et on ne peut s
exexclure succccès bloquiste pls
imimportant qu'on ne le prévoit.
MaMalheureusement ce n'est pas n
acaccident cette question. Cela
rérévèle de plus profond n'a pas
étété réglé dans le vieux
cocontentieux Québec Canada.
CaCanada comme système politique
esest disposé a célébré toutes s
nonotes de la galaxie sauf la
grgrippe québécoise. Il y a un
mémépris par intermittence poure
QuQuébec depuis le début du
CaCanada. Quelque chose qu'on na
papas réglé. On a de souveraineé
mamais ça ne l'a pas réglé.
QuQuelque chose de la conquête i
esest encore là et qui sont
inintervalles réguliers. Très
prprofond, n'est pas une. Ce n't
papas étonnant si ça a un effete
mama compagne. C'est très
inintéressant car n'est pas le
susuperficiel. Dans les 23 jours
cecela peut évoluer.
- - G fait référence a cela touà
l'l'heure. Au salon bleu de
l'l'Assemblée nationale.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - Depuis quelques jours,
lele premier ministre a succombé
àà l'un de ses pires défauts.
IlIl s'est mis à faire sa
memeilleure imitation de Maurice
DuDuplessis. Il s'est autoproclé
ppère de la nation québécoise.
- - Le chef de Québec solidaire
nonous parle de Maurice Dupless.
IlIl avait beaucoup de défauts,
mamais il défendait sa nation.
IlIl n'était pas un "woke" comme
lele chef de Québec solidaire.
- - Et cela s'est poursuivi.
NoNous on a de l'ambition pour e
QuQuébec, le faire pays pour des
ininfirmières sur les écoles.
- - Le chagrin de sortir du sac.
OnOn a tous bien entendus de
QuQuébec solidaire qui a dû
dédéfendre les compétences du
QuQuébec face à Ottawa. Cela ne
m'm'intéresse pas. Cela veut die
ququ'on attend un référendum sur
lala souveraineté.
- - Alex Barrette le premier.
WoWoke, c'est éveillé en anglai.
CeCe que son MBA toute injustic,
raracisme dans la société est
dedevenu un terme qu'on utilise
auaux gens qui ne voient à peu
prprès que cela pour ceux qui
ututilisent négativement?
- - envoie le prisme des
ininégalités sociales et de la
didiscrimination d'abord par
l'l'identité et non pas par la
clclasse sociale. C'est beaucoup
cecela le wok. On a parlé beaucp
dedepuis quelques mois. Je troue
quque c'est assez révélateur que
ririsque de voir dans l'année
prprochaine Assemblée nationale.
C'C'est-à-dire que l'identité de
QuQuébec solidaire est claire. s
sasavent où ils s'en vont, dans
leles termes forts. On peut les
aiaimer ou ne pas les aimer pour
rereprendre les mots de Hélène.e
didiscours est clair. Gabriella
NaNadeau Dubois est un
paparlementaire assez habile et
c'c'était de confrontation fait
soson affaire parce qu'il y a ds
gegens qui ne sont pas d'accord
avavec François Legault la manie
dodont il a géré la campagne
élélectorale fédérale. Est-ce qe
enentre-temps un référendum sura
sosouveraineté de Québec
sosolidaire?
hohonnêtement, je pense que
FrFrançois Legault a poussé le
bobouchon un peu loin. Mais ça a
êêtre un débat intéressant, en e
DuDubé assez intéressant entre
QuQuébec solidaire et la coalitn
avavenir Québec une année.
ZiZidansek de chacun sont clair.
- - Christian?
- - c'est comme si je reconnus
l'l'un et l'autre comme émis coe
prprincipal adversaire. Leur
susurvie dans l'année électorale
c'c'est Éric Duhaime. Le nouveau
paparti conservateur qui est le
seseul parti, qui monte et le sl
ququi conteste la gestion de la
dedemi-part François Legault.
AuAutant il y a eu un ralliement
trtrès imposante de François
LeLegault les désagréments pas é
d'accord. Et il y a aussi
GaGabriella Nadeau Dubois qui et
reredoutable. Je crois que Québc
sosolidaire est redoutable. C'et
trtrès impressionnant la
coconcentration cet après-midi.
QuQuand on dit également haine
ququ'il ne faut pas prononcer
égégalement des eu ne pouvait ps
didire et il est sorti de
DuDuplessis. La comparaison de
FrFrançois Legault avec Dupless.
CeCe québécois mais on a donné
auaussi précis que Duplessis on
l'l'attaque en disant que c'estn
momonarque.
- - Deux courants.
- - Quant à Monsieur Legault, cs
mumulticulturalismes. Un woke
c'c'est beaucoup plus malsain.
CeCela peut devenir le opposante
gogouvernement. Quand je dis la
dédépense des compétences
ququébécoises de je n'ai rien
asassuré ça m'intéresse pas
bebeaucoup. Je ne pense pas qu'l
pupuisse perdre de chemin de la
didilection qui est arrivée
auaujourd'hui, on entre autres
chchoses. Les libéraux entre
auautres de la page hier le
sysystème se renouvelle.
- - Christian de quelque chose
d'd'intéressant. Ils se sont
rereconnus. Je pense que les dex
onont fait mouche en attaquant
DuDuplessis et l'autre woke. Les
obobjets puisque chacun incarnaa
mamanière. Je pense qu'on a rain
dede dire quels sont les deux
grgrandes tendances désormais. s
papartis centristes qui
trtraditionnellement étaient un
amamalgame de plusieurs courants
dede la gauche, la droite sont n
peperte de vitesse. Et donc que
ououi, cette dichotomie entre la
CACAQ et Québec solidaire vientn
pepeu dans la sphère politique
vevenait confirmer cette
prprésentation à laquelle on
asassiste dans la société et qui
sese traduit dans le monde
popolitique. Oui, c'est quand me
asassez intéressant de voir cete
didifférence très marquée entre
leles deux. Évidemment, ce Nadeu
DuDubois avec les Québec
sosolidaire, et dit moi, les
cocompétences ne m'intéressent
papas. Il est dans le même du ca
OtOttawa. Ne s'il y a un problèe
enensemble et on s'en fout de la
reresponsabilité de qui.
- - Je suis indépendantiste mais
enen attendant, s'il faut partar
cececi ou cela, on ne deviendra
papas faux.
NeNe viendra pas fou. Avez-vous
unune alarme?
- - je pense que mon micro-onde
ququi est arrivée au bout de son
cycycle..
- - moi, cela m'a donné envie au
prprochain débat a Québec le dét
dede Québec va être quelque cho.
AvAvec ces deux-là entre autres.